la policía le ganó el primer round al
gobierno argentino en una batalla de
largo aliento por exigir mejores
condiciones laborales los uniformados de
la provincia de buenos aires anunciaron
el cese de las protestas que por primera
vez llegaron hasta la residencia del
presidente argentino luego de que el
gobernador anunciara que aumentaría el
salario de más de 39 mil efectivos de la
capital argentina donde habitan unas 17
millones de personas va a ver una
equiparación inmediata de 39 mil 521
oficiales de policía
que pasarán a percibir un salario de
bolsillo de 44 mil pesos esto equivale
más o menos a 557 dólares anteriormente
ganaban unos 502 dólares pero este
aumento del 11 por ciento les parece
insuficiente no sólo porque la semana
pasada el presidente alberto fernández
aprobó una inversión de 460 millones de
dólares para reforzar la seguridad de la
provincia de buenos aires donde los
delitos aumentaron en un 30% sino porque
su trabajo se multiplicó por la pandemia
que demandó mayor pie de fuerza debido a
las restricciones agradecemos que nos
puedan dar una mesa de diálogo pero no
podemos llegar a un acuerdo porque
nuestro primer mundo fundamental que
pedimos no fue escuchado y ni siquiera
lo nombraron este fuerte no queremos que
escriban a nuestro compañero no nos
garantiza que saliendo no vamos a
terminar sumariados
los policías esperan que el gobierno
cumpla y que sus condiciones empiecen a
mejorar pero la desconfianza estatal
crece en un país que lleva más de dos
años en recesión económica y ahora
batalla por superar la pandemia